I'll smile from where it takes to fool this town I'll do it till the sun goes down
I'm knocked with a night time Oh yeah, oh yeah, I'll tell you what you want to hear
I'll get my sunglasses on while I shed a tear, but now we're the right time
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
I'm on top of the world, I'm a budget with no breaks, I'm invincible
Yeah, I will never sing the name, I'm so powerful, I don't need batteries to play
I'm so confident, yeah, I'm on top of the day
I'm on top of the day, I'm on top of the day, I'm on top of the day
I'm on top of the day, I'm gone, only alone I will cry, I'm now
You'll never see who I'm tired and now, I don't know deep down
Yeah, yeah, I know I've heard that that you're feeling shows
You all know where to make fun trips go, but I'm too afraid to Pure tonight
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
I'm on top of the world, I'm a budget with no breaks, I'm invincible
Yeah, I will never sing the whole day
Mine's a powerful, I don't need batteries to play
I'm so confident, yeah, I'm unstoppable today
I'm unstoppable today, I'm unstoppable today
I'm unstoppable today
I put my eyes on you as one, yeah
I put my arm on, I'll show you that
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
I'm unstoppable
I'm a pusher with no breaks
I'm invincible
Yeah, I will never sing the whole day
Mine's a powerful, I don't need batteries to play
I'm so confident, yeah, I'm unstoppable today
I'm unstoppable today